grand prix statement was released
earlier this afternoon which said
formula one can confirm it has
terminated its contract with the russian
grand prix promoter meaning russia will
not have a race in the future
and this morning there was a u-turn by
the international paralympic committee
meaning that athletes from russia and
belarus cannot now take part in the
winter paralympics in beijing which get
underway tomorrow the ipc reversed its
decision following widespread
international criticism
we have decided to refuse
the athlete entries from rpc
and npc belarus to the per athletes from
the impacted countries we are very sorry
that you are affected by the decisions
or yoga that your government took last
week in bridging the olympic truce you
are victims of your government's actions
and here's what the culture secretary
nadine doris had to say on the decision
there are other powerful ways of
isolating rogue regimes
culture and sport can be equally as
effective as economic sanctions if used
in the right way
culture is the third front in the
ukrainian wall
across sport across the arts and
entertainment we're ostracizing putin on
the global stage
putin is now suffering a sporting and
cultural siberia of its own making
before we head to the break let's take a
quick check on today's weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
today mild and less windy than it has
been recently with cloud and patchy rain
edging eastwards much of britain is
going to be murky this afternoon with
hill fog and outbreaks of rain but
eastern england looks mainly fine
meanwhile island and northern ireland
will be brighter with just a few showers
mainly in the west that rain will move a
little further east allowing more of
west wales and the southwest of england
to dry up there'll be some late sunshine
there as well
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
coming up after the break it is our live
q and a session with a panel of experts
on this ukraine invasion they'll be
answering your questions uh that's
coming up in a couple of minutes time
stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back to sky news time now
to get answers to some of your questions
about what is happening in ukraine i
have with me uh our panel of experts uh
security and defense analyst michael
clark a familiar face to you here on sky
news over the last couple of days are
also joined by keith giles a senior
consulting fellow on the russia and
eurasia program at chatham house and dr
heather papowitz an emergency management
specialist at the world health
organization uh thank you to you all for
joining us here so many viewers getting
in touch so many questions and mike i'll
come to you first if i may uh this
question is um is there any way this
could end with putin's demands satisfied
enough that russia withdraws from
ukraine
very difficult to see since uh mr putin
has said that ukraine has no right to
exist that it's not a real state so what
is this a negotiate about however the
fighting from ukraine's point of view
has got to stop or they will lose
completely so there is a possibility of
saying well let's at least talk let's to
stop the fighting let's talk about the
possibility of something like the
austrian state treaty of 1955 which
guarantees neutrality for a country in
europe at least as a model there the
ukrainians won't agree to it but they
might start talking about it in order to
live to fight another day yeah okay i'll
put that question to you as well um
within the last half an hour we heard
about a conversation at the request of
vladimir putin that he speak to the
french president emmanuel macron and he
reiterated calls to demilitarize ukraine
and he reiterated his demands and saying
that you know unless they're met this
invasion will continue
that's exactly right and in fact he said
that unless there is a a rapid uh
meeting by ukraine office demands he
will actually present more demands
rather than fewer but michael clark is
absolutely right uh what they said to
negotiate about when effectively putin
has demanded the destruction of ukraine
as a state
and kier here's a really interesting one
and it's something we've been discussing
more over the last couple of days uh
since the invasion this comes from a
viewer that says what do you believe an
average russian knows about this
conflict what do you think they support
pro where war or pro-peace
and how long do you think this conflict
will last it's interesting isn't it
because we have seen protests on the
streets of russia
there have been process yes and the
interesting thing is how exactly are
those people getting their information
from the outside world about what's
going on because russia has spent years
trying to prevent that kind of
information from actually reaching its
population the clampdowns not only on
traditional media but also on social
media trying to put these filters in
place between russia and the outside
world so the only picture they get of
what is going on is what's being
delivered to them by state media which
of course is still at this point talking
about a special operation in those
eastern provinces of ukraine and
pretending that the main invasion isn't
actually happening so somehow russians
are in fact getting this information and
they're not happy about it and there are
some very brave individuals not just
among ordinary people but actually
prominent individuals within russia who
are making their opposition to the war
felt and they know that they will be
risking consequences as russia clamps
down even further on dissent inside the
country yeah michael how tightly can
russia control the flow of information
in the country obviously we know that
state media trots out putin's lines that
you know
that is it but there is the rise of
social media there you know russians
have friends and relatives in the west
that will be hearing what's going on yes
i mean they're giving it a good try to
clamp right down and they've done a
great deal in the last two years to
clamp down and arrest people and close
down social media and um
vaguely independent news sources but
they haven't done it completely and
you're absolutely right they don't just
have people friends in the west they
have lots of friends and family in
ukraine
and the telephone system has got to be
up and running at some point in the
future so it may be a drip drip of truth
but the truth will never be absent from
russian society but it may take a while
for it to get through and remember that
i mean president putin isn't that
unpopular within the within the broad
society because most russians most
ordinary russians think well he's put us
back on the map again and he's done some
useful things it will take time if we're
thinking about a broad movement towards
truth and understanding on the part of
the russian population but it will
happen yeah time the ukrainian people
though sadly don't have let's um look at
this next question which i'll put to all
three of you
what would nato's response be if russia
deployed a chemical biological or
nuclear weapon in ukraine this is the
worst case that reo that so many people
are thinking about and it's giving
people uh sleepless nights michael can
you give us your take on this first yeah
we we crossed the line in syria in 2013
in appearing to condone or
tolerate the use of chemical weapons
there's always been an enormous
threshold chemical biological were out
of out of reach uh and of course nuclear
is completely out of reach well we've
we've crossed one of those thresholds in
syria if it were used in ukraine the
condemnation would be huge would nato
attack russia because of it no they
wouldn't
they won't because that would be war but
the the condemnation would be off the
scale to anything that we've seen so far
yeah kim michael mentioned syria there
but it happened a little bit closer to
home in the uk the use of novichok in
salisbury so many people say you know
this this kind of warfare has already
begun what do you think that the west's
response would be if it gets that worst
case scenario
well as far as nato is concerned
unfortunately nato made it very clear
from the very early stages of this
crisis that it was abandoning ukraine to
its fate
nato member states were saying no there
won't be any intervention in direct
military support to ukraine and that
effectively gave putin the green light
to move in so as we've seen with the
discussion over in imposing no-fly zones
over the last few days anything that
western countries now did to try to
protect ukraine would be an escalation
would be in fact attacking russia
fighting their way into trying to
protect ukraine and fulfilling all of
president putin's fantasies so it would
be a huge step in the other direction
now a reversal of all of nato's policy
to actually step in and try to protect
ukraine when it's already declared it's
not going to yeah heather i'm sure that
comes as what we've heard from michael
and kia there offers no solace to the
people that would be affected by some
kind of chemical weapons attack
biological or nuclear
what does that mean for
a humanitarian mission i mean it's
unimaginable and it would make any work
of a humanitarian effort team
really really difficult if it isn't if
if it isn't really difficult already
yeah um i think you hit it right there
it's actually already
extremely challenging to provide health
care our staff on the ground are working
from bunkers listening to bombing at
night
health staff have to go to hospitals
that are being
targeted
we have one documented attack actual
attack on a hospital we have others that
we're looking at so right now it's
extremely unsafe to provide health care
for the health workers going to work
we've already heard just uh
from staff on the ground a nurse was
shot in the streets um other health
staff are leaving so really the the um
access to health care right now is
already as
constrained as it could possibly be
uh so this would be a whole other layer
on what's already significantly
challenging right now yeah heather how
difficult is it to get
aid into ukraine at the moment obviously
we've seen the masses of people trying
to get out it's a situation that's very
much in flux from one area of the
country
to another but we've heard talk of
people appealing for there to be
humanitarian corridors to be agreed with
russia that seems to be very slow moving
but is that what's going to be the vital
piece for your work
yeah i think that would um that's
definitely vital um having that access
that uh safe access for humanitarian aid
for us to get
medical supplies in to get staff in um
and to get just people on the ground to
help support the response that would
significantly support that but we're
still we're we're still working so
humanitarian aid is still continuing to
the people that need it on the ground uh
but it's the access has been uh
you know significantly constrained but
we are still working doing our best um
at all hours to try to get uh support to
the people who need it yeah no matter
how bad it gets that humanitarian effort
continues um michael let's talk about
this question if the war stops tomorrow
what happens to putin are restrictions
lifted will he be welcomed back or are
we now entering a new cold war
yes i think the world changed last
thursday
this is day eight of the new world that
we are now in because last thursday was
a bit like 9 11 a bit like the november
the 11th when the wall came down in 1989
nothing will be the same again
afterwards and whatever happens now
we are now we in europe are dealing with
a revisionist russia we're not going to
try and baby mr putin along anymore
we're not going to try and pretend that
we can live with it and deal with it and
contain him this man or russia under his
leadership
has shown itself to be a threat to
european security and a big problem for
world politics so we'll we won't go back
to the way we were of hoping that we
could somehow get along with him if the
war stopped tomorrow
then we're still with that reality and
of course the wall won't stop tomorrow
and my own view is that this is this is
peak putin after this he's finished
i don't know how long that will take it
might be some years might actually be
quite quick might even be quite sudden
but he's got nowhere to go after this
because he's now in the category of
saddam hussein or colonel gaddafi he's
the pariah leader and whereas mr
zolensky has emerged as the greatest
figure of the 21st century so far mr
putin is now the greatest tyrant the
greatest vandal of the 21st century so
far he's got nowhere to go yeah i mean
michael put it there very succinctly
vladimir putin in the same category as
saddam hussein and colonel gaddafi
in that sense he's got nothing to lose
why would he stop the war now which
takes away all hope for the people of
ukraine it's it's all on nothing now for
putin
nothing at the moment
her president put him from pushing
forward and when he's offered an
off-ramp and a de-escalation and a way
of stepping back from the crisis that
tends to overlook the fact that as far
as he's concerned he is winning but just
coming back to what michael said yes i
think we have finally reached a turning
point where for once russia will not be
welcomed back and people won't try to
return to business as usual afterwards
the really amazing thing about the last
week for long-term russia watches has
been not the invasion but the fact that
europe has finally woken up to the
challenge it has been facing for all
these years and realized that it needs
to deal with russia as an aggressor
which may threaten other countries next
that's what's really changed here as
opposed to russia's behavior and the
direction that russia was traveling in
uh heather i have a question here from
josephine who has got in touch with us
she says how will governments make it
safe for all people in ukraine to leave
if they need to given that we are seeing
airports being bombed and other routes
out like train stations and land borders
either restricted or severely damaged
um
i mean again looking at the uh the safe
passage so having um that humanitarian
uh
um
assistance and having the uh the
corridors for people to come and go um i
know now uh i think today we were upward
of
uh a million people crossing the border
and they're coming in exhausted from
weeks of a week of being uh in a very
critical situation i mean after two
years of covid so they've they've had
significantly reduced access already to
essential services including health care
um so they're coming over the border and
really need to have
assistance there as well so uh we're
looking at uh providing that
at the border and the host and the
countries that are hosting uh the people
coming in uh kia this is quite a timely
question given the news we heard from
the uk government is trying to come up
with special legislation something to
speed along um these sanctions for
oligarchs this question says is freezing
assets enough why can't assets be sold
and funds held for ukraine rebuilding
yes the uk's response to the problem of
russian dirty money and its influence on
russian domestic politics has been an
ongoing challenge in dealing with russia
again it's nothing new it's a problem
which has been flagged up long before
and the reluctance of the british
government in particular to grip that
problem and deal with it has been deeply
damaging to efforts to try to constrain
president putin however when we are
looking at freezing the assets of
oligarchs
questions need to be asked not only
about where the money came from but also
what the actual effect of that is going
to be because often the influence or
that oligarchs have on president putin
or even the major businessman have on
that inner circle that makes decision
within russia may be overstated what
we've seen over the last period is
president putin where it's preaching
further and further down his own rabbit
hole of conspiracy theories about what's
happening in the outside world when he
seems to have been in isolation because
of potentially his fears about covet so
what exactly are people going to do to
try to change his mind if they're not
if they don't have that direct access to
putin to complain to him
uh here's a question that illustrates
just how far-reaching this conflict is
um it
ends up in space are the us and uk
michael do you think still going to
participate in joint russian space
missions i mean or is everything on the
table for
ties being cut yeah there was a lot of
cooperation between the americans and
the russians in space during the 90s
after the cold war which has now
sort of
just dribbled to not very much but the
russians still launch
british satellites and european
satellites from their stations they said
yesterday that they'd stopped doing it
and that's not surprising because that's
a tit-for-tat sort of response i think
we have to accept that things like this
space cooperation things that were
perfectly sensible normal functional
arrangements will probably all come to
an end for the time being some of them
might be restarted again but it really
all depends on where we are with mr
putin's government
in three or four months time and indeed
if he is still leading the government in
three or four months time so for now we
have to accept that's one of the
collateral damages i think from this
whole uh
miserable war of which there will be
many and let's talk about this next
question uh michael i'll put it to you
how easy or hard will it be for putin to
consolidate or hold the territorial
gains he's made in ukraine so far
completely impossible
um there's a rule of uh military
policing and civil order that in an
ordered society
you need about two people per thousand
as police people as policemen or women
two per thousand in a troubled society
you need twenty per thousand
so in a society that's that's in a state
of insurgency twenty per thousand have
got to be in the security forces just
work it out if if ukrainians or 45
million people if they don't want the
russians there and even one percent of
ukrainian society is prepared to do
something about it and attack the
russians they simply would need about a
million troops in order to hold down
ukraine it is a sheer impossibility and
president putin has landed himself with
a totally unrealistic scenario of
dominating a country that hates him that
hates the russians or russian soldiers
and he's determined not to be suppressed
it's an impossible situation for him
even if he wins the war of the cities
which of course is now in full flood
yeah it just comes down to basic maths
isn't it everybody is talking about this
conflict i was actually talking to
somebody in the makeup room before they
came in they said oh one million
refugees have left the country
already but aren't there over 40 million
people in ukraine that's a lot of people
left to put up a resistance as you said
kiera i'd like to get your take on that
excuse me michael is absolutely right
that it may be hard for russia to
control an insurgency a resistance
movement against its occupation but we
also have to look at the fact that over
the long term moscow has a 100 success
rate at suppressing resistance movements
of that kind through vicious savage
brutal repression and are not counting
the cost of civilian casualties and the
destruction that they wreak when they
are trying to do so that is what we need
to bear in mind when thinking about the
word resistance it's not a romantic
affair it's not some the way we think of
it in the west as perhaps the french
resistance during the second world war
it will be absolutely savage and it will
be scorched earth tactics by the
russians to try to suppress it in the
way that they know how and that is the
reason why one of the main indicators
that an invasion was in fact imminent
was the move up to the ukrainian border
of russia's national guard for australia
the internal security force that is
designed to suppress russia's own
population including using heavy
weaponry all possible but also
specifically designed to control
territories occupied territories of
places that russia has just invaded so
russia does appear to be prepared for
this and the past precedence of how
russia goes about suppressing these
kinds of movements is something which
should give anybody that is intending to
embark on them serious pause for thought
i just want to squeeze in a couple of
quick questions before um time is up um
michael how are all these weapons that
the west is sending being secured what
if they're confiscated by the russians
well they may be they may be captured
but most of what we've sent are fairly
small i mean shoulder launched or
anti-personnel weapons um the chances
are that they will be destroyed rather
than be captured so i don't think many
of those will fall into russian hands as
it were
uh this uh
question why don't the ukrainians bomb
the stationary russian convoys michael
i've been asked that a lot because we've
been talking for the last two days now
about that 40 mile long russian convoy
heading towards the capital kiev it's
slow progress a lot of people saying we
can see where it is why isn't it being
attacked yeah if we had our air power
we'd take it out completely but the
ukrainians don't have that sort of air
power left it seems but also they have
been bombing it they've been using their
bay raktar missile the bioreactor drones
the turkish drones but also their
punisher drones that they've developed
themselves electric drones which are
stealthy can't be picked up easily they
only carry one bomb but they've been
very clever and they've been trying to
bomb the fuel and the ammunition parts
of the convoy in order to slow the whole
thing down so rather than trying to
destroy hundreds of hundreds of vehicles
they've been trying to destroy the the
enablers to hundreds of vehicles and the
russians are making a complete mess of
keeping this armed convoy on the move
final question to you heather again lots
of people asking this what is the best
way to help the people of ukraine we've
seen pictures of european cities around
the world donations being made physical
donations baby clothes food um you know
blankets and the like but the mayor of
london sadiq khan said the other day
look actually money is more useful
donate money not physical items what is
the best way for people watching this
unfold at home feeling helpless to help
those most at need
yeah um that's exactly it uh give money
and
supplies and other necessary items will
be bought based on the needs on the
ground so there are the teams on the
ground are looking at the needs and
making assessments and they'll know what
exactly is needed what medical supplies
um what other type of supplies are
needed so giving money is the best way
and that way they can tailor uh the um
the response to what is needed at the
time okay heather really good to hear
from you dr heather papowitz emergency
management specialist the world health
organization michael clark our resident
security and defense analyst and keir
giles senior consulting fellow on the
russia and eurasia program at chatham
house thank you so much a fascinating
and frightening discussion in equal
measure we'll have more after this short
break
[Music]
[Music]
you